eine mutter sie tötet ihre drei kinder
ertränkt sie am strand von new york es
ist der fall der horror mutter von
brooklyn der uns an diesem tag so bewegt
spaziergängern die leichen der drei
kinder am strand gefunden die drei
geschwister ein junger vier monate ein
mädchen vier jahre und noch ein junge 7
jahre alt gerade in die schule gekommen
ja sie alle hat ihre mutter ertränkte
mehr vor new york sie hatte offenbar
hohe schulden ein sorgerechtsstreit sie
sollte aus ihrer wohnung fliegen dass
die bilder dort vom tatort also dort ist
diese horror tat begangen worden und das
ist es was die polizei dazu sagt
die mutter war also klatschnass ob sie
im regen oder im wasser weist an dieser
stelle spekulativ sie war nass sie war
barfuß und sie hat mit den beamten nicht
kommuniziert
[Musik]